-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden spoke today at
a DNC event to thank staffers
and volunteers.
Okay, but you know
who you really
need to be thanking, right?
I mean, the way his endorsements
performed,
this man needs a fruit basket,
which would be a solid burn,
because he doesn't eat fruit.
[ Laughter ]
Following Democrats'
surprisingly strong performance
in the midterms, White House
chief of staff Ron Klain
tweeted yesterday,
"Never underestimate how much
Team Biden is underestimated."
[ Laughter ]
And wow, what a rallying cry.
That's like if Coach Taylor
said, "Clear eyes,
full hearts, everyone thinks
we're going to lose.
But guess what.
We're not going to lose
by as much as everyone thought
and we're going to call
that a win.
Go get 'em."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's
daughter Tiffany is reportedly
worried that Tropical Storm
Nicole will ruin
her wedding this weekend
at Mar-a-Lago.
Though if I were her,
I'd be more worried about
this tropical depression.
[ Laughter ]
Just moping around, complaining
about the midterms, jumping in
front to catch the bouquet,
and yelling, "This means
I'm the nominee in 2024."
[ Laughter ]
Allies of former President Trump
are reportedly telling him
to delay his planned 2024
campaign announcement,
so now he has to come up with
a new explanation
for what his big announcement
was.
"Uh, we're launching Trump brand
hard seltzer."
[ Laughter ]
"That was always the plan
and not something
we just threw together."
Pennsylvania Republican Senate
candidate Dr. Mehmet Oz conceded
yesterday in a phone call
to Lieutenant Governor
John Fetterman.
Fetterman knew it was him
because it was not
a Pennsylvania number.
[ Laughter ]
Ex-Trump organization CFO Allen
Weisselberg recently testified
that former President Trump
inflated the value of
his Trump Tower apartment
by $200 million,
which he did by claiming
it was a two-bedroom.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
It's a joke about New York City
real estate, but...
[ Laughter ]
I'll explain
during the commercial.
[ Laughter ]
A T-Rex dinosaur skull will go
up for auction next month and is
expected to sell for 20 million
of Nic Cage's dollars.
[ Laughter ]
A professional archer in Denmark
recently broke a Guinness
world record by shooting
seven arrows through a keyhole.
Great for him, terrible for
his nosy neighbor.
[ Laughter ]
Is that a two-bedroom?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Phew.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, organizers of the
Westminster Kennel Club Dog Show
have announced that next year's
event will be moved
from Madison Square Garden
to Billie Jean King National
Tennis Center in Queens.
What could possibly go wrong?
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.
We're off.
We got a great show for you
tonight.